c'est la russie qui affirme avoir tiré
des coups de semonce en direction d'un
avion militaire britannique au maire
noir à lui reproche d'avoir violé sa
frontière de son côté londres ni ses
tirs à moscou la correspondance
d'antoine clairoix à 11h52 heure locale
lundi ce trailer britanniques auraient
pénétré dans les eaux territoriales
russe en mer noire alors que le navire
ne répondait pas aux avertissements
russe et bien d'après les autorités un
navire garde côtes puis un avion de
chasse russes auraient donc effectué des
tirs de semonce en direction du navire
britannique ce qui aurait donc provoquer
le changement de cap du navire en
question un incident qualifié de
provocation du côté du ministère russe
des affaires étrangères
le ministère russe de la défense a déjà
donné une évaluation des manoeuvres
dangereuses du destroyer de la marine
britannique dans la mer noire je tiens à
ajouter que nous considérons cela comme
une provocation flagrante de la part de
la grande bretagne qui va à l'encontre
du droit international et de la
législation russe
en outre je tiens à ajouter que le
ministère russe des affaires étrangères
convoquera l'ambassadeur dû royaume uni
à la suite de cet accrochage l'attaché
militaire britannique a donc été
convoqué à la direction de coopération
militaire mais pour londres
cela ne s'est pas passé tout à fait
comme ça en effet la défense britannique
assure que son avis en a été la cible
d'aucun tir et que le navire en question
ne faisait je cite que croiser dans les
eaux ukrainiennes cet incident met donc
en relief le risque élevé d escalade
militaire dans cette région du monde
une région dans laquelle des acteurs de
très nombreuses nationalités sont
présents